cnn just hired that guy that got caught
spanking it on the webcam i mean they
have no integrity at all and if you
really this is this is advice for the
viewers out there if you want to see
what someone someone is about
look at the fruits of their labor cnn
attacks grandmothers who make facebook
pages attacks other journalists attacks
people like us independent journalists
they punch down when you look at
independent media when you look at other
people that do actual reporting they're
punching up they're going after actual
institutions with actual power that
actually have an effect on your life you
look at who gets targeted that's how you
should judge a person and judge a news
organization by it's not just the media
i mean it's the cultural left the
democratic party what are they going
after this tiny sect of trump supporters
as evil and it's like you guys control
all the cultural institutions in the
government you're the big guy stomping
on a little guy but i absolutely love
how cnn went to the home of an old woman
and started yelling questions at her in
full view of her house and address and
that's okay social media twitter got no
problem with it james o'keefe blurs the
address and confront somebody banned
all right that was very project veritas
i believe that's what got their their
official account banned then eventually
they twitter does ban james o'keefe
you know i think it's fairly obvious
james o'keefe project veritas all of the
great reporters they do great journalism
empowered by people like you who blow
the whistle and call out the malfeasance
and that's really scary to to the
establishment
there's
it's like they defeated journalism they
were these these evil uh uh demonic
individuals were probably laughing that
journalism had finally been conquered
was over then along comes small
independent channels small organizations
like project veritas and they grow and
people becoming more successful now look
how panicked they are they never know if
whoever they're talking to could be
undercover for project veritas i've
never cared you know why the sing the
things i say privately are the same
things i say on this show 100 exactly
that's how i feel now don't get me wrong
like the narrative of you have nothing
to hide you have nothing to worry about
is very bad when it comes to an
authoritarian uh police state
but you look at these companies and how
worried they are about how someone could
be veritas in the security protocols
they got to do and it's kind of like
be honest like if if somebody from
veritas secretly recorded somebody who
worked here and said something dumb i'd
be like well i guess i said something
dumb i don't know
there you go exactly exactly yeah
media's uh it's kind of like they're
functioning as a paramilitary corp the
media like they're an arm of the
secretive because if you're in the
military you can't say whatever you have
you have clearance and classification
and you're under strict orders not to
and
it's all it seems like they've been
they've been co-opted to do information
the job of the military it really is i
mean generational warfare and now here
these people are whipping people into
shape and getting them in line and
telling them what to think and what to
do
you know what's funny is uh when it
comes to second the second amendment you
get these uh these anti-gun democrats
who are like do you really think you're
gonna go to war with the united states
government they got nuclear missiles and
the first response is you can't occupy a
street corner with a nuclear missile are
you dumb you look at afghanistan vietnam
it's it's an individual with a gun which
can control a neighborhood or a building
or resources
and then i think about it
you don't need to occupy the street at
all if you occupy the minds of the
people if the only information they can
get access to tells them whatever you
want them to think well there you go you
know and i'll mention this because i
used to watch star trek the next
generation all the time i've seen every
episode a million times but before the
show and people commented i should watch
stargate sg1 so i started watching
stargate sg-1 and in this show advanced
aliens pretend to be gods to control and
manipulate human populations to use them
as slaves that's what i'm talking about
dude so i brought up lucifer earlier
just saying well so but the idea is they
don't need to to use weapons to
subjugate these people they've convinced
them of an ideology and those people are
willingly serving now
i think that i think that we're doing
that without realizing it i mean we're
working
100 well the alien disclosures are
coming very soon it's going to be
nothing with the new york post just
reporting quote ufos could threaten u.s
security politicians say after capitol
hill briefing i'm suspicious that's a
distraction yeah yeah when you have
barack obama and neil degrasse tyson
talking about how there's ufos out there
and how we need more money for the
military yeah you should start asking
yourself some questions about what's
really going on here because uh it's not
usually what they say right yeah oh
they're using the ufos as an excuse to
get more military barack obama made a
specific statement saying you know we're
going to find out that aliens are real
and this is going to mean we're going to
have to increase the military budget
that's his own words uh from but what if
aliens are real could be there's there's
a possibility in there we have to be
intellectually honest i i think there is
a big chance that they are but what if
obama is basically ozzie mendius staging
a fake alien invasion to force people to
unite
and and give up their freedoms like in
the pandemic i just hope that's not the
case you know yeah well we'll see time
will play out but the best friend you
could have is skepticism in this modern
day and age where information
is that block 17 you know
firearms second uh there's a reason the
first amendment was first second
amendment is second uh they protect each
other they're very integral and uh
people in gated communities and private
bodyguards shouldn't be telling people
that they need to be disarmed um i think
i think people need to become more
responsible you know as much as we can
rag on the authoritarian move for the
great reset i can certainly i can
certainly say while
authoritarianism the manipulation of
people through through lies and
deception all that's wrong
hey man people need to start becoming
more responsible for themselves
self-reliant everybody should go out you
know
be like more responsible for the food
they eat we grow grass in our lawns
that's a stupid idea we should have
gardens with vegetables that you can
grow and you can be responsible for some
of the food you eat you should exercise
you should read books get away from the
cities pollute less be you know more in
tune with what it's like to actually
survive and be responsible for yourself
and you know what this criticism is
mostly towards people in cities because
the people in the rural areas basically
know all this already the people in
cities live in cubicles stacked on top
of each other in cities that smell like
sour milk and then complain about the
problems they've created these people
need to to to get with the program and
learn how to be human again you practice
what you preach when did you move out
here we're in the country well so
someone chatted beginning the show that
you know i only decided to move out to
the middle of nowhere once i had money
and it's like i i moved to the middle i
was in i was in far i was on a farm in
the redlands which is basically 40 miles
outside of miami i don't pretend like
it's the most rural place ever but i
lived on a farm with chickens like this
was this is 2015. this is when i was
working for fusion i didn't want to be
in a city back then
and so i did move back to the new york
area and then slowly moved away and now
we're more in the middle of nowhere but
not in the middle east of nowhere i will
say once starlink goes live we'll
probably go way more middle of nowhere
but the we're trying to strike the
balance between people can fly here
pretty easily
and we're kind of far away from you know
big cities so we've got a big garden
we're growing vegetables we've got
chickens man so we got one chicken it
was a rehome laying eggs every day we
got too many eggs already because we
don't eat eggs every day so we had like
six today and i was like wow so i'd be
like i gotta eat these eggs and then but
we've got six other we've got five other
chickens turns out one of them's a
rooster so we're going to have tons of
eggs all the time we're going to have
like six eggs per day and that's that's
just from the chickens eating the bugs
the bugs eat the grass and they give us
eggs
being responsible more for ourselves
that's that's what i'm saying you know
we we are getting uh solar panels
installed we're we're trying to be more
energy efficient we're uh we have our
own water system we want to have an
electrical system
when i talk about environmentalism i
mean it you know we
we we have occurred oh yeah but we use
these these corn plastic biodegradable
cups that aren't like regular cups you
look at these celebrities they talk
about climate change they don't actually
mean it they fly in private jets they
they live in these big mansions they
consume ridiculous ridiculous amounts of
power they buy beachfront property while
claiming the beaches are are going to be
wiped out by rising ocean water and i'm
like that that's just hypocrisy
you know what
too many people live in these cities
they're they're gluttonous they do very
little work in exchange for tons of
money while thinking they're poor and
i'm not trying to be mean to people who
live in cities who think they're poor
but man
if you live in a big city and you can
walk outside and go for a buck get a
cheeseburger you're you're doing better
than 99.9 percent of the entire planet
and now they've they've lived in such a
way that they've lost touch with what it
actually means to be responsible for
your own health and safety and security
they've deferred everything to the
mainstream media to tell them what to do
and what to think and then they complain
about it they complain about the system
instead of realizing they're being lied
to and it's time to roll up your sleeves
and actually do some hard work
amen
i think people are getting that more
than
more people than ever are not trusting
the media
yeah
and i'm optimistic you know i i i'm
fairly pessimistic in terms of talking
about war and and conflict and
especially with you know joe biden
saying the fed you know people should
snitch on their family members and the
feds wanting to go after extremists
but i think about hey
we're doing really well we're hiring
people we've got a newsroom just
launching there's a lot of difficult you
know challenges ahead but i'm i'm 100
confident we're going to succeed and if
and and operating under that assumption
what does the next five 10 years look
like a large independent news outlet
challenging the lies in the mainstream
media and helping clear away the noise
helping people understand what's
actually happening and choose for
themselves how they should live and how
they should vote
that makes me optimistic i mean we're
doing something here we're gonna bring
in more people to do more things
everybody else should should do the same
agreed yeah we're working on uh what
have you ever heard of the fetiverse no
it's that that's uh it's like different
social networks like mastodon and and
other types i don't know there's a few
other ones that where they all
interoperate all these different social
networks so like you could you could be
on like minds and i could be on youtube
and i could subscribe to your mind's
channel and then tim could be on twitter
and subscribe to me on youtube from
twitter and then we can all have like
our own feeds whereas they'd be like
your website my website tim's with all
of our own independent sites
very cool oh my gosh
yeah yeah that's going to be the future
of independent media because up until
internet video there what independent
media i don't know what it was alex
jones screaming in his on the radio then
it was youtube but then we realized that
it's not independent if it's on if it's
on corporate yeah it was publicly access
alex jones got to start by literally
going down to the local public access
station that filmed on some cable news
channels and that was where he got his
start so this will be the next public
access but we're going to have to get
off the isps that'll be the big next
step after we get off the social
internet service provider so like
verizon
um could shut down your internet access
if they didn't like amazon with uh
parlor right yeah amazon has the hosting
service so then you also have your dns
uh which could shut down your so you've
got to get off the isps and you can go
oh i see wow oh my gosh um yeah it's a
big big problem i mean it's so we're
wired in it's going to be there yeah
we've got to figure that out the goal is
to create an open source software that
the average person can just
put on put on like you you go to a
server company you know a server service
then you install this program which
gives you a basic subscription service
website so imagine sub stack but it's
yours it's your website with your open
source code operating this and then
people who like your content can become
members sign up to pay so that you can
you can do your own work the goal of
this is let's say you start a sub stack
which is where a lot of these journals
have gone well they can ban you they can
say we don't like what you're saying
imagine you start a patreon
they will ban you because they've
already done that to a lot of people so
we want to make something that's harder
to ban not impossible to ban i mean your
domain registrar or your server company
they could still terminate services to
you but it eliminate it makes it harder
to do so oh you know hopefully we get to
that point where people can just
buy buy server space buy a domain
drop a program into their server and
execute it and then boom they've got a
functioning website add some graphics
done you probably will happen as we'll
have mesh networks and our phones will
be our servers i think that'll be the
future
wow yeah that'd be that'd be a great
idea there's uh there's actually apps
that do this so i went on a cruise
several years ago
no there's no phone service so what they
did was everyone would turn on bluetooth
and you downloaded this app where it
connects every phone to each other
so if you send a message to your friend
who's on the other side of the cruise
your phones
will your phone will hit this guy's
phone with that guy's phone and then
bounce around all the way until it makes
it to the end and then that guy gets the
message so each phone was acting like a
cell tower it's amazing yeah they did
something similar at burning man but but
just very curiously i mean you just did
this do you have any plans moving
forward we're going to be going from
here
i i want to continue doing independent
journalism somehow
i'm just i'm really i have a bad taste
in my mouth about corporate news i i
don't want to be a part of any
corporation
and i really am craving some solitude
right now like just being
alone for a while i am working on this
really important story that i mentioned
to you guys of finishing bringing this
full circle that what started with dr
varone last august
and and fox clamping down so hard on
that story
i'm digging back in and saying let's get
to the bottom what have we learned in in
a year
let's talk to the researchers the
doctors and i even got a one-on-one with
world health work guys wow yeah so i'm
looking forward to putting i've already
shot this story i'm gonna put it out so
i'm i'm already working
on on this first independent report and
um
i i want to continue doing journalism
you know and
i want to
yeah i just want to be authentic and
and not owned by anyone and i just want
some freedom and peace and and i i do
need to figure out how to monetize
myself
um but you know i'm i'm open to a lot of
things um i want to keep doing
journalism but i also
i i love my music and i have all these
songs that came like through inspiration
like a lot of my songs come in my sleep
it's just like completely inspired so i
want to just
work on my songs because i haven't had
time with
all the chaos that happened with fox
i and um and then fitness is another
thing i'm passionate about and i
actually when when i really was like
okay it's i've got to get out of fox i
actually bought a personal training
program and i was like oh i'm gonna get
certified as a personal trainer
because i enjoy fitness and um
you know
why not monetize something you enjoy so
i'm i'm open to doing like a few
different things and just you know
continuing to do what i'm passionate
about right on thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you